in the trailer and we've seen a still
before of Halle Berry with the dogs I
think all of us are very curious about
those dogs and Halle Berry what can you
tease um well I think anyone that's seen
the first chadwick knows were a bit of a
dog movie if you can't tell that again
at the time my co-director Dave Leitch
and I are dog people or animal people I
was mostly a cat first but now I have
two puppies dave has always been a dog
person we love animals that's awesome
and because that was such a motivational
factor of the first movie we teased a
little bit about what the people in the
second film and this one we're like well
let's not just have the dog as a
background or a set piece or prop let's
actually integrate what we can so I went
around with my stuck part of my name my
action choreographer John Eusebio and we
interviewed every dog trainer that we
could find in Hollywood and Beyond and
came back with with Andrew Simpson who's
our one of the best wolf guys in the
vistas Game of Thrones and I don't know
if most people know but when a dog
attacks like when you see a dog attack
on screen or in a film the dog doesn't
know it's a movie it's an animal
attacking a man in in the mentality of
I'm gonna bite and chew this person up
so we wanted to find a trainer that was
willing to take younger adolescent
animals or puppies and train them so
that the attacking or the interaction
with some people was fun it was a game
it wasn't life or death ever wasn't an
animal protecting himself in like that
and lo and behold we found somebody that
was willing to go through that so we
managed to find these beautiful animals
just like in addition five Belgian
Malinois dogs like Belgian Shepherds
that all had above-average intelligence
and physical ability we actually had dog
editions for a couple months and found
them from all around the United States
brought them to Los Angeles and for five
months train the dogs to do interactive
stunts with stuntmen know at the same
time we didn't want a trainer just
hiding behind a set piece or proper zone
like that so we wanted Hallie or our
Sophie our character to be the on-screen
dog trainer so it wasn't acting like
these were her dogs they actually were
her dogs so
when we cast Hallie we had the big talk
and how he actually came after all their
fight rehearsals and Governor results
she would go sit work and play with the
dogs for months on end so the dogs
actually on-screen obey Hallie and
they're not looking at a trainer so that
was really fun and as if John the puppy
in the first movie was symbolic of his
wife and his loss the dogs in in
Parabellum are symbolic of someone that
Hallie's lost and that's our time and
rather than being just passive like a
puppy these dogs are a little bit more
active in the story what were you able
to that first of all that's crazy and
amazing second of all what were you able
to do with the dogs on screen that maybe
surprised you or what were there any
limitations or you came up with these
ideas and the dogs did yeah no um it was
it's it's like anything we get it you
know even a human a cast member and
you're trying to find the marks or the
choreography fit for them some people
are more flexible some people are
stronger some people are shorter some
people are taller so you try to tailor
fit the choreography to them same with
dogs like we all thought we didn't we
wanted but then you have to go through
the process of okay the dog just doesn't
react to action and cut like our process
is we went through all the dogs trying
to do all the motions we thought of and
let the dogs kind of play and we started
experimenting and the dogs naturally do
certain kind of motions better
especially Belgian Malinois badeck very
very tough and absolutely fearless when
it comes to Heights so we tried to use
that to our to our benefit dogs just
like people out of the five Belgians
that we have all five have different
personalities surprisingly different
personalities some Santana what you'll
see is one of the main attack dogs and
Sam are the two most athletic but also
the two goofiest so if you see a dog
making a goofy face it's probably
Santana the most serious is a female
called Boyka and you know if she was in
a bad mood that's not the one you wanted
on set so he just had to pick the mood
of the dog depending on whether it was
running jumping hopping biting attacking
flipping and we would choose a
personality based on the stunts that we
would do process wise what's digitally
moved is the stunt guys put on a special
kind of pad
it's colored green it's like almost a
really bright green and the dog has been
trained that go after the green toy
don't want anything but the green toy so
wherever the stunt man put the green toy
or our little green chewy toy they will
velcro it on their tent and that's what
the dog would go after so we've wanted
to groin hit the summer a a Velcro green
on the groin if it was a forearm you'd
be on the forum back on back and we'd
come up with all these straps of the dog
knew when I see green get green as long
as you didn't we were green on set to
work that day you're doing great so
there's no green allowed on set for
anything true other than that the dogs
responded to that and then we do it we
do a rehearsal a doggy would pull off
the velcro green chewy toy he'd have to
go in his quiet box so the dog would
calm back down it was about a two minute
whoo okay it's all fun it's good and
then he'd come back in and do the second
take and once you realized what was the
best for the the animals the dog and the
process of how to get the most takes and
how to get the most precise takes out of
them we just reverse engineered back how
to put in the choreography and we wanted
to show in the movie so we do a lot of
just like our John Wood version of we
don't cut a lot we try to do longer
takes a track with Halle and see the
dogs actually doing it so you know we
just didn't cheat and did an insert of a
dog chewing on something